hey guys is Charlie so today we're going
to be talking about Deadpool two
behind-the-scenes drama reportedly
Tim Miller the director of the first
Deadpool movie has dropped out of the
sequel because he is clashing with Ryan
Reynolds over their vision of what the
sequel should be it's a little more
boring to be honest because last year I
had a big movie here this year I'm just
another face in the crowd again but you
know what I like that my 22nd comic-con
and
I really just like mixing
people that love to kind of [ __ ] that I
do that's why I made the movie or that's
why I wanted to make a movie
I feel like I'm part of this great
brotherhood and sisterhood or people
that love this kind of material so I
have
but it is a little little down from last
year because all H was this sort of
moment in time where I don't think
anybody realized how how big a thing the
movie was going to be and I get a little
choked up
but
that moment up on stage with Ryan was
just a wonderful thing where we both
realize for the first time just how many
people love this character and
there's great thing so the biggest point
of contention is that Tim Miller who's
this visual effects person like he owns
a visual effects studio who is largely
responsible for the look of the first
Deadpool movie is envisioning a more
stylized polished sequel and he's
reportedly the one who's going after
Kyle Chandler to play cable earlier this
year it was rumored that they'd been
testing him and he was the strongest
candidate for that character you know
not someone who looks like huge and
hulking who you normally think would
play cable but a great actor Kyle
Chandler is amazing but it just depends
on what you want your superhero movie to
look and feel like and that's really
what's going on here because on the
other side of this Ryan Reynolds is more
of a comedy guy like an r-rated raunchy
comedy guy and he wants the sequel to
lean more into that so in the way that
Deadpool was really funny you had all
those great jokes Ryan Reynolds seems
like he wants to double down on that Tim
Miller on the other side of that wants
it to be a little bit more serious and
just look a little bit more mind-blowing
just you know more visual effects bigger
action set-pieces things that a more
visual storyteller might be interested
in focusing on in Tim Miller just to be
clear he owns a visual effects studio
that did most of the work on the first
Deadpool movie so like that's where that
leaked Deadpool test footage came from
even though you know way back at
comic-con if you remember a couple years
ago I'll actually I'll play the video
here just a second but that footage came
from Tim Miller studio now it was just a
work print so it looks kind of raw but
I'll play it right here
mmm [ __ ] it's nice you can say bananas
hey [ __ ] yes
oh hello there I bet you're wondering
why the red suit well that's so bad guys
can't see me bleed
hey let's hope these guys have earned
their brown pants hola me llamo piscina
de la Muerta there's no easy way to say
this I'm pregnant Trevor rich curricula
crying the disease meet the cure okay
but not the cure but more like a topical
ointment that reduces swelling an itch
hi Tom time to make the chimi [ __ ]
chunga's have you seen this man
I never say this but don't swallow
[ __ ] did I leave the stove on so you can
see how they expanded on that in the
final movie when they did that big
action set piece on the freeway so it
looked great Tim Miller was a great
director in reportedly he did a lot of
free work on the film like we went way
above and beyond the call of duty to
make the Deadpool movie look amazing and
on the other side of that so did Ryan
Reynolds like way more than you would
expect a lead actor to take authorship
in their film a film that they didn't
write or that they're not directing now
it's different when say like Ben Affleck
writes a screenplay for the new Batman
movie then directs it you expect him to
be highly invested in it but initially
Ryan Reynolds was just a hired gun so to
speak but then obviously Deadpool
development stalled out a couple years
ago supposedly he is the person who
leaked that test footage ahead of Comic
Con they got the studio interested in
doing the actual movie so you know
people want to see this maybe we should
actually do this and then throughout the
entire process
Ryan RAL just like non-stop marathon
promoted the film personally working
with the marketing department to take
authorship not only over the movie
itself but over the way they were
marketing the film in the Deadpool
marketing team at Fox just won a major
award for their marketing campaign
that's a whole other amazing story if I
have more time later tonight I'll
totally do another video about that just
about the marketing campaign Deadpool
kills all other movies when it comes to
marketing but Ryan Reynolds versus Tim
Miller so they have a big disagreement
over what the tone of the film should be
what it should look like and who should
play some of its major stars so normally
you would expect a director in the
studio to have final say on what the
film looks like who gets cast things
like that it's pretty normal but because
it almost seems like the Deadpool
character is Ryan Reynolds agent he was
able to renegotiate his contract with
the studio for the sequel get way more
money and way more control over the film
which is normal for this kind of
situation with this level of actor like
if he was a nobody actor he wouldn't get
a lot of control over the film he might
get more money but he wouldn't get a lot
of control
Ben Affleck he's a good example of that
he's in the Justice League film he
doesn't have total control over Justice
League just because he's not directing
it he's only starring in it but he's
such a bankable star now that the studio
would listen to him if he complained
about stuff so because of Ryan Reynolds
new contract the studio is backing him
in this disagreement so whoever ends up
being cable whoever ends up being Domino
just know that Bryan Reynolds will be
like sitting there approving them
personally so if you do trust Ryan
Reynolds sensibility when it comes to
the character in the property the movie
is going to be fine so if you wonder why
you haven't heard a lot about the movie
lately it's because there's been a big
hold up over the actors that are getting
cast in the tone of the film in general
which is a pretty big deal so now that
Tim Miller has moved on to another movie
at Fox hopefully things will move
forward a lot quicker they'll announce
their Cable really soon they'll announce
their Domino all the other supporting
characters and we can start freaking out
again but it just is pushing the release
date of the film more and more so I
think that's what people are most upset
about just the fact that there's been a
holdup making us have to wait longer to
get the movie but let me know in the
comments who do you want them to cast
for cable in Domino they're still
testing a whole bunch of people almost
everybody in Hollywood the Deadpool
movie made so much money that there is
no way that they are not going to
nitpick everything about every little
detail but thankfully you know Ryan
Reynolds has a lot of control so he can
be the final word and say this is how
we're gonna do it in the studio we'll
probably listen to him just because he
is such a big part of the film without
Ryan Reynolds there is no Deadpool
sequel that is the real reason they got
rid of Tim Miller so what's going to
happen next is is I mentioned that
really awesome Deadpool marketing
campaign I'll post that video next I
should post later tonight but it's just
an amazing breakdown of how Ryan
Reynolds in the studio just completely
destroyed every other movie marketing
campaign last year it really came out of
nowhere in the fact that the Deadpool
character is so crazy just allowed them
to have a lot more fun than you would
with the traditional x-men film or like
a big blockbuster even Captain America
Civil War so be sure to subscribe to get
that in
there are any other Deadpool videos that
you guys want me to do just let me know
in the comments so new outro just a
little bit different why you guys wait
for that video to post you can click up
top for the Logan red band trailer again
and you can click down here for the
guardians of the galaxy trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight